it was an emotional night for American
Idol hopeful fire Wilmore I think you
naturally get really
um emotionally tired of these kids and
their struggles and their Journeys
earlier this month viewers watched the
22 year
job as a stripper and provide a better
life for her three-year-old daughter
audition in New Orleans with her little
girl by her sides she's a handful but
she's also my best friend do you want to
come sit up here with us while mommy
sings Come on right here this way her
performance of Talking to the Moon by
Bruno Mars wasn't quite strong enough
for Lionel and Luke
sorry
to know for me I fire gosh I'm so sorry
it's going to be a no for me but Katie
twier to come back
comeback show in Asheville that's where
you're going to show us what the fire is
we support them we nurture them we give
them constructive criticism and even if
they don't win American Idol they go
home just like full of so much hope and
fires Hope was on full display Sunday as
she returned without her daughter and
without any distractions the judges took
notice they look lighter and brighter
um that whole situation that happened in
New Orleans honestly I wasn't focused it
was a bit of a handful having my
daughter how did I know yeah we we got
that right away it's hard yeah so I went
and sang songs all day every day in my
house everywhere I need to prove that I
deserve the second chance I'm working
I'm working on working for my daughter I
want to make her proud add virus
performance of Adele's love in the dark
was well fire
[Music]
before
what's beautiful about this is yes you
have talent but if you have a heart and
talent we've scored a major Point all
three judges noted that there's still
some room for improvement are you the
best singer we've seen not at all but
there's just stuff about you that I'd
really like to push you on they're
really entering into a university as
Lionel likes to put a a crash course a
fast pace
crash course of the music industry
Wildfire has officially enrolled in the
University of American Idol because it's
a yes for me
I'm excited to see what kind of
butterfly you turn into
it's a yes for me
[Music]
I'm excited to see you bloom into your
fullest potential
it's a yes thank you
thank you